(drum music)
- [Narrator] Power.
Energy.
Synchronization.
Fluidity.
These are all words that
describe Taiko drumming
as we see and hear it today.
Known as the heartbeat of Japan
the art form, balances,
music, dance, and athletics
into a dynamic demonstration
of Japanese culture.
- The word Taiko means drum in Japanese.
- This is Kumidaiko, an
ensemble based form of Taiko.
and if you've ever seen a
Taiko performance before
this might be what you recognize.
There are two things that may surprise you
about this art form.
One,
that it was developed as recently as 1951
and two
that it may not exist without
the influence of jazz.
(upbeat music)
So I'm a drummer and my background
is in jazz and in gospel
but I've never played Taiko before,
so in this video, Linda
and I are gonna learn
about Kumidaiko and
I'm going to get a Taiko lesson later on
and see how it compares to jazz drumming.
- Hey welcome.
- [Chiaki] I'm Chiaki
- Chaiki?
- Yes.
- And I'm Jen,
- Jen
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet y'all
- Gonna just start with
some very, very basic things
like just breathing.
This is the way we start
a rehearsal or a class
is three different breaths, big breaths.
And the final thing is
there's a ki that's the vocal
part of Taiko and ki is just
an expression of the spirit.
Also sometimes it's,
you know, it's written
it's part of the music.
Everyone who learns
the song, learns the ki
to go with it.
But a lot of times is
just how you feel in the
moment.
- Yo!
- Yes. Rhythmic instruments
have existed in Japan
for around 2000 years.
Drums brought in from China
were adapted into a uniquely
Japanese style, a style that
facilitated the practice
of Shinto, an indigenous
Japanese religion in which
worships, ancestors and
nature spirits through
the spiritual art form.
Taiko became an intimate part
of many village activities.
Taiko would later become
a big part of Chai ki
or religious festivals.
Every town in ancient Japan
would hold their own festivals
that began to incorporate
Taiko, drumming and dancing due
to their deep resonant
sounds, Taiko were also used
by the military and towns folk
as a way to deliver messages
or signals across large
distances for hundreds of years
Taiko existed in these two ways,
as an essential part of
dancing at religious festivals
and a communication device.
- In 1951, a jazz drummer
named Daihachi Oguchi was
asked to play an old sheet
of Taiko music discovered in an attic when
he was finally able to interpret
the old Japanese notation.
He discovered that the
music was extremely simple
because it was written
to be played in unison.
He began toying with
new, more complex ideas
and later realized that
different types of Taiko played
by a group of people could
be used to effectively
emulate a Western drum set.
- These midsize drums
here we call the Chu Daiko
- Chu Daiko.
- And they generally hold the melody,
- okay.
- And this is just very general.
- Okay.
- Over here,
- Chu Daiko.
- Okay.
- This is the Shime Daiko.
Shimesza means to tighten.
And so you can tighten
with bolts or rope as
the highest pitch sound.
And that's usually your
timekeeper, your, your beekeeper
your G keeper.
- I like that.
- Yeah.
- The Shime is very similar
to the snare drum in
- Absolutely.
Exactly. Totally.
- So this is the big base.
This is our largest drum,
which is the Odaiko.
- Oh Odaiko.
- Oh, Odaiko.
- This is Tiffany Tamari Buchi.
Not only was she the
first female foreigner to
win an Odaiko competition in Japan.
She also created the first all
women Taiko Onsombo, Jodaiko.
I wanna know.
How did you choose to play the Odaiko?
Was it that power that was a part of it?
Or were you just drawn to it?
- Yeah, I was drawn to the
physicality and the power in it.
And the overall style
of it, the way it really
involves your whole body,
the way it involves a lot of spirit
and a lot of presence and a lot of power.
I had a motivation to learn the style
and as I started to do
it, I actually learned
I was pretty good at it.
- And then we added the phrases
right.So,
- okay.
- The phrases are simple.
So, uumm,Don
- Don.
- Hit in the center.
- Ka hit on the wood and
then how you play it is how you say it.
So yes,
- I'll say it.
Don, Don KA, Don.
- All right.
So, Don
(drumming continues)
- Various Kumi Daiko
groups were established
in the 1950s and 60s.
Some of these groups such
as Kodo still exist and
perform around the world today
- Taiko existed prior to 1951
but the art form was completely
reinvented. since then,
Kumi Daiko has spread to
all corners of the world.
It became a way for Japanese Americans to
reclaim their Japanese heritage inspired
by the civil rights movement in the 1960s
- To connect with that part of culture.
And that part of history
is important to me.
And so to be able to, as a
Japanese American connect
with that part of my heritage in Japan
and to be accepted as a woman
and as an American and as a
a Taiko player was also important
to me and my sense of identity.
- You know, these drums
are huge and they take so
much physical power and that's
something that, you know
regardless of traditions,
that's something that's really
identified as male.
And when you, when you flip
that and have these gorgeous
amazing women playing so
powerfully, but playing
with their own kind of energy
and experience, it's,
it's sort of revolutionary
- Speed.
Nice.
- Okay.
- So like
- Yes, like that now, now
after you hit do this hit
and just make sure there
you go, there you go.
- Yes. Do that hit
- Now on the way out? ah, float
float, float, float, float, float, float
float all the way back.
So pretty.
- Okay.
- Until you're ready to hit again,
- Hit again
- And then float
and then Like your laser
cutting across the sky.
Float all the way, all the way back.
- You look much bigger.
- Yep.
- Like, so
- Yeah. Ooh, look at that.
- Okay. One more.
- Oh
- Okay. Okay.
Yeah. You gotta be strong to, to do
- Don doko doko doko don doko.
Don huh! Don huh! Dn huh!
- ka and Don is just boom and ka.
- Yeah.
- To me,
- right.
- Boom. In the center.
ka, ka, ka on edge.
- Ah, ka.
- So same idea.
Yep. Boom, boom, ka , boom, boom, boom ka.
Oh, boom, boom.
Same thing.
- Yeah.
- Can we, can we play together?
- Yeah. I'd love to.
- Can you play a rhythm?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Okay. So I'll say my way.
- Yes,
- but, but we'll figure it out
how to say it the Taiko way.
Okay. And this is how it goes.
It goes like this 1, 2, 3, like
this boom, boom, boom, Boom
Ka ,boom, boom, ka ,boom ,boom , .
- Taiko has brought together
communities of all ages
and genders to play in
dance to the heartbeat of
Japan. The two
- Thanks so much for watching
our episode on Taiko drumming.
If you want more on Taiko, be
sure to check out this video
on if CDs could dance,
Tiffany shares with us
how Taiko has impacted her life
and how it keeps her community
in Sacramento strong.
- And here are your submissions
from our last video where
we ask you what your favorite
Brandy vocal moment is.
- Brandy's catalog is
without a doubt iconic
but I have to say my favorite song
for Brandy's off her
latest album, be seven.
And it's called borderline
the vocal harmonies
in that song is absolutely ridiculous.
I, I still lose words
when I think of the song.